pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing company
dedicated to making the very best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to wear
not to wear out visit grip6.com pogchimps
playing with the white pieces in this first game
and she has a very unique opening i don't know
if you have heard of this opening cutie it's
called the bird's opening when you push the f
pawn at the very start to f4 she's
playing so you're playing fast holy moly
they're both playing fast they're both over the
10 minute mark i don't mind that oh she missed it
i i think oh yeah sorry i i was seeing it
uh with a bit of a time difference uh she
hasn't noticed yet that the bishop on f5
is hanging the rook could take it she's
attacking the the rook on a8 but now if the
rook moves that will attack the bishop on bf7
what do you think he moves the rook that's
a good move now both bishops are hanging
and queen trade we love one of those um why
oh interesting oh no nico didn't spot the
hanging it's gonna be it's gonna be trade fiesta
bishop is hanging wait i have a free check
oh they both just have don't know bishops out
there living their best life bishop to d4 check
by myth is a really strong move because he could
take the bishop of nico for free yes check me
checkmate uh maybe not jackman just yet
but the bishop the bishop is hanging
oh
uh oh
the realization that two of which is regarding
this we had no clue and now after capturing
the pawn on a7 she has a past pawn that a3 pawn
could be a potential queen but it's still f for
from promotion the evaluation bar has jumped
but i don't think this is obvious what what's
going on um the knight is now on a square that is
disconnecting the black bishop from from that pond
there's the pawn she's nico's been staring at
that pond for the last few moves true ever since
you mentioned that she had that bishop of capture
with the rooks hanging i think she has seen it too
now this is tough for myth because suddenly he is
down upon he was up upon and the past two moves
he lost two pawns excellent yeah the thought
process that the right one that's exactly the
right one because you need to try to stop the
pawn with the rook but then the knight will be
in trouble so that's why this rook move by nico
earlier pinning the knight was a great decision
and i think she knows it that now her
position oh miss is attacking both the
rook and the bishop but the rook on b2 was
unprotected now it's a full rook up for nico
oh poor myth um he fought very well
but eventually the experience of
nico has decided i think some of the most critical
moments when everything was hanging nico kept her
cool and calculated better okay so looking
at this nico still has seven whole minutes
i don't understand how she's so fast
is anna
great perfect this is this is awesome um
anna looks lovely and i'm totally cut out for
this and you guys are enjoying yourselves and
we're having a good time and nico is gonna
take this w she's just gonna laddermate
any second now myth is gonna fight it at
this point this is when everyone in chat
spams very toxically and they tell you to
resign but nico's got it that feels good
and we are back hey cutie how's it
going good nothing has changed you
saved chess from their worst nightmare
which was me representing them alone
so happy to have you here i'm gonna
be honest i watch you on chess tv
all the time and you're fantastic so i don't
think it's so nice there's no saving needed
just all of the chat's hair they're just pulling
it out well we do have central control by myth and
nico moving quickly she typically does so she
plays really fast she does and i i wonder she said
before like sometimes she just feels like she
needs to move and that helps her chest she's
gained a lot of rating throughout this pogchamps
she's up to 872. she started i think in the 500s
well nico is going for an aggressive plan with c5
striking the center and the engine bar just jumped
up here and it's because white can continue taking
space with a pawn push to e5 but it's very natural
that myth would take the pawn i think that's our
first instinct okay pawn has been taken by myth
and now that bar drops but it's so tricky
because when you're playing you obviously
don't have the bar and even while watching
it may not be clear but a large reason why is
this bishop on e3 normal developing move this
knight can come to g4 and this bishop on g7
is the best piece on the board i think he will
take the blame as any good coach should yeah i
do think you are learning things and well nico
she's striking here with a5 she's pushing all of
her pieces forward and i don't think that myth has
a plan so actually when you look at this position
what are some ideas that you can see here
i mean if i were myth i would start moving
my knights his knights need to get out there
playing somehow am i crazy no no but he just
lost his bishop for a pawn there he oh
took there and the bishop was captured
so i think he's really sad for him i thought
it was free and ended up not being the case
the b4 square not very well defended but also
nico has more time she started with niko's amazing
with time it blows my mind i mean she's just
too fast and she honestly maybe there should
be a bullet tournament with all you getting one
minute on the clock i think she could win it oh
okay so using your idea though to get the bishop
out but could drop in 94. yeah i think we're just
going to lose that night well that's just a trade
i suppose correct well a pawn was taken and oh the
engine did not like that move so the big issue and
she just took a knight on c3 is that this king has
been out in the open so actually just a move ago
queen out to b6 check puts this king in a world of
hurt but knight 63 you can't complain about that
as she took a piece and she still is up material
and he just doesn't have any pieces remaining so
i guess at a certain point he can shuffle and he
needs to be careful because now this pawn is under
attack in addition to the check he's been checked
again yeah interesting uh-huh and he moves king
up so that was really smart because if this pawn
had been captured uh let's say you make this move
and the pawns captured you also lose your queen at
the end of the line so he was smart to make the
move that he did king up and he comes the queen
so is nico just going to keep pinning trying to
get that queen is that i think that's what she's
going to try to do yeah she gave the check to she
can just trade queens and then win the end game
and bring her king up and then moving her pawns
she is our queen i've said it i've said it so
now you're yes she's yours she's yours too we live
in this state you and i the state of chess.com and
we decide who our queen is and it is nico today
okay and by we decide you mean i decide okay god
i just want to make sure we didn't even say in
that yes yes absolutely we're on the same page
because chad has decided that you
are their queen though it seems
oh i'm not deserving of such an honor i voted
for nico chad voted for hess i guess hess will
wear the crown today he has a little more votes
i suppose oh well i guess we have to do a poll to
see what they really think right it's the only way
through true true run the numbers yeah we're data
people here and it's running this pawn is running
queen is happening i think nico has us under
control the only question i have is will she have
more than 10 minutes when the game ends i hope so
i'll be interested to see where did how many
matches has niko won this will be her first
yes of your first match win that'll
awesome awesome awesome awesome
but be careful about the sail mate okay the king
has one move so it wasn't stalemate and now the
king has some space but that was actually
pretty close she's making a third queen
i hope so she's playing with her food but
be careful not to stalemate when you have
too many queens you could accidentally
allow your opponent to get a stalemate
just make sure no mercy no mercy me nico i
almost said mikko uh-oh freudian slip wow
no one tell mika i'm thinking about her
it's okay she must shoot off into space yeah
mars oh one point's gone that was interesting
myth was so confused said what there it is oh
there it is there's the finale two nothing for
nico and myth was just absolutely startled by the
queen can i can i take that he probably shouldn't
have taken it would have given him better
stalemate chances yeah that's a good point
nico first off congrats how does it feel to score
your first dub um it feels good um i really was
feeling a little down because i was like i really
did lose to little boy benji and then a french
dude named chasardosh so i was like i need to get
some kind of win and luckily myth was like hey i'm
gonna let niko win and i was like nice a silver
platter on a silver platter here yeah well cutie's
cat was rooting for you miss he is my cat oh my
gosh really would you say hi to my son please he's
let's go i have one finally but i'm the
biggest nico simp so nice split household crazy
so she did great today yeah i mean nico so you
were playing really quickly did you just we're
feeling it today i mean what was your mindset
going in uh taking on myth in this matchup i mean
i wasn't i wasn't uh far from myths elo reading
like three weeks ago and i just got back into
like grinding chess and i feel like i've already
been playing for like over a year so i kind of
already knew what the mindset is at that elo
so i feel like i had like an advantage there
um and and yeah so so i was i kind of
already was in myth shoes not too long ago
so i feel like i already had like an
advantage in that sense she said that elo
how do you feel about that myth that evo
dude i feel like i it wasn't even a battle
today then dude i stepped into nico's
world that's what happened today exactly
i stepped dude is anybody here watching juicy
kaizen she just pulled you know she pulled out her
realm and engulfed me at it that's what happened
today i didn't know what i was getting into
you